don't ever come at me like I saw God
I'll punch you in your face
so do it season 18 of Keeping Up with
the Kardashians started off with a bang
well actually was more like a rotten
flesh went down literally on Thursdays
season 18 premiere Courtney makes it
pretty damn clear that she's over
filming the show
I'm just so you know over glam i Don
asleep don't want to film like ever
again
later she was overheard complaining
about having to pay for her own trip to
Costa Rica
well things all came to a head when Kim
made this comment about her sister's
work ethic mom is so used to me Courtney
me and Chloe going on our new beds yeah
Courtney no likey she straight up
through her water at Kim calling her a
choice four-letter word and the savagery
kicked off but also if I didn't want to
work my ass off and I wanted to be a
stay-at-home mom
that's fine you literally let me remind
you all be slapping and nail scratching
is over courts work ethic yep court work
ethic
I don't want to hear this narrative
anymore but about this work ethic and
she's the only one with work ethic and
she's doing this this and this as if
she's better because she works for bands
will have to wait until next week to
find out what happens next
it's just tune in because you never know
what's gonna happen well according to
court she is officially done with the
show after the show aired the 40 year
old got called out on Twitter by a fan
who wrote Kourtney Kardashian just needs
to quit the damn show I'm over her not
wanting to film courts response I did
buy and a mic drop the mama of three
also made it clear that she and Kim
aren't completely over their beef
telling another fan on Twitter that her
sisters never apologize and they don't
actually see where my hurt comes from
which brings us to Chloe
o who responded wait so no one ever
apologizes to you
lol please can we get Kris Jenner up
here to fix this pronto I wasn't there
when they had that argument and I have
not seen them really fight like that
since they were in high school back in
February Chris opened up about the brawl
during a stop at Ellen didn't anybody
see when Kim beat one of the kids over
the head with her purse because her rims
on her car weren't right or I it was so
silly oh we remember it it was season 2
of Keeping Up the year was 2008 and Kim
blessed us with this now iconic moment
in pop culture history classic it took
me back to that but it made me really
sad mama Kris also dish on rumors that
Kourt was ready to ditch the family's
reality TV show she's filming again okay
is it no because I gave her some of this
right is that I mean so much she wasn't
gonna be in it and she's in it what
changed your mind I think she just
needed a little bit of a break you know
how we all hit a tipping point and she
hit a wall and she was frustrated and
she felt underappreciated that her
sisters didn't understand her boundaries
and so I think after you know taking a
little bit of time off she's
seen the light but et sat down with
Court she weighed in on all of that
chatter - you mentioned that you might
be ready to say goodbye to Keeping Up
with the Kardashians where are you at on
that um I've just decided to spend more
time as a mom and you know put more of
my energy there and still but I'm not
saying goodbye do you think the show can
continue going if you lose a sister we
definitely love Courtney and we will
miss Courtney and whatever she decides
to do but people come people go this
family we are feel like it's a revolving
door so party you might leave this week
she'll be back they all come back
[Music]